we begin with some breaking news Germany
has expelled two Russian diplomats over
the brazen killing of a Georgian citizen
in Berlin prosecutors suspect Russian or
Chechen involvement in the attack the
victim has been named as Salim Khan
Kangas Philly a former Chechen rebel
commander he was shot dead in broad
daylight in a public park last August a
suspect named only as Bardem M has been
taken into custody Russia denies any
involvement and says it will retaliate
against the expulsion 'he's now DW s
political correspondent kate brady is
following that story for us welcome Kate
first tell us about the expulsion of
these two Russian diplomats and the
circumstances well what we know so far
is that the foreign ministry here in
Berlin released a statement just within
the last hour or two saying that two
Russian diplomats were being expelled
from the Russian embassy now it's not
clear yet exactly what positions they
held there at the Russian embassy here
in Berlin but what we do know is that
they were working at the Embassy they
were here as diplomats and as such are
now being expelled from the country the
foreign ministry said that this was due
to information from the German German
federal prosecution which indicated that
Moscow could have been behind this
killing now of course that is still to
be confirmed but in its statement the
German Foreign Ministry said that it
have reached out to Russian authorities
on several occasions since this killing
in August for more clarity on this
killing and said that the that they had
not yet had a sufficient explanation or
help from Russian authorities and so on
the grounds of this information from the
German federal prosecution they decided
to take action and expel these two
Russian diplomats ok kids stay with us
for a bit because let's first take a
look at this report with low details on
the killing
soon after the assassination in Berlin
suspicions arose that the Russian
intelligence services were involved the
victim
georgian national fought in the chechen
war against russia the suspected killer
is a 49 year old russian currently in
custody Germany's Federal prosecutor's
office has now officially taken over the
investigation
Spanish food awfully indeed there's a
lot of evidence including the fact that
the suspect was already wanted for
murder in Russia then he disappeared
before reappearing under a new identity
that's one of the key factors here the
killing in Berlin could be similar to
the poison gas attack carried out in
Britain on double agent sergey
skripnikov did many Western countries to
impose sanctions on Russia the Russian
government meanwhile has consistently
denied any involvement and is refusing
to cooperate in the investigation
ready Kate what do we know about the man
who's been killed his name dazzling can
can go Swilley and why he might have
been the target of an assassination he
was killed just around the corner from
here in the Kleinert air gotten in
August of this year and what we know so
far is that he was an asylum seeker of
Chechen descent from Georgia and he
actually fought on against the Russians
in the second chechen war in the early
2000 so he fought against the Russians
and also after the war he reportedly
also worked in Ukraine and in Georgia
and those were thought to be on jobs
that were against Russian interests of
what we've learned so far
and DW actually spoke to his ex-wife
earlier this year as well and in her
words she said referring to his killing
we were warned that this would happen
eventually interestingly as well as I
mentioned he had applied for asylum here
in Germany and that was rejected and he
had actually been slated for deportation
and as everything we know about the
victim so far but of course as this
inquiry goes on it seems that we will
most likely learn more about his
background and connections to Russia as
is most indeed likely the case as well
for the suspected
perpetrator and what about the man that
the German police has taken into custody
he's been named as vadym em have any
more details emerged about him well what
we know so far from the prosecution is
that he was actually wanted for our
suspected murder already in Russia and
that has as we heard there in the report
played a key role
apparently so far in the prosecution's
investigation of course he is still in
custody and of course as this case
develops it's now in the hands of the
federal prosecution which worth pointing
out they usually only take care of cases
which are seen as a crime against the
state which gives you an indication of
the severity of this case and how this
is being regarded both by the German
government and by the federal
prosecution here in Germany but we will
be expecting to just get more
information as those investigations
continue now of course Moscow has
reacted with anger to the expulsion of
the two diplomats can you tell us about
the Russian reaction well the Russian
reaction was almost immediate earlier
today once those two Russian diplomats
were expelled from Berlin now Russia has
said that well he denied once again
actually this afternoon the Kremlin
spokesperson denied any Russian
involvement or involvement of Russian
authorities in that killing in in August
and it retaliate I said as well the the
Kremlin said that it would be
retaliating with similar sanctions so we
could expect to you see German diplomats
expelled from Russia or even other
sanctions and the Kremlin described the
expulsion of these two Russian diplomats
as unfriendly and unfounded and that it
would be as I mentioned retaliating as
what it said accordingly and in a
similar manner to which Germany has
reacted so far cute pretty GWS political
correspondent thank you very much for
that